en la introducción a la ecología
hablamos sobre la comunidad que se trata
de diferentes poblaciones que se
encuentran en el mismo hábitat es decir
que comparten una misma área entonces
poblaciones
por ejemplo si pensamos en algo como el
agua o el aire
podemos decir que comparten un mismo
volumen poblaciones que comparten un
hábitat
y en este vídeo nos enfocaremos en las
interacciones entre diferentes especies
y el término técnico para eso es
interacciones inter específicas pero a
mí me gusta decir interacciones entre
especies ahora lo primero de lo que
hablaremos es de la noción de
competencia la competencia es cuando
diferentes poblaciones o especies
compiten por los mismos recursos por
ejemplo imaginen un bosque en el que
existen diferentes poblaciones de
plantas que compiten por la luz del sol
por el agua y por los nutrientes del
suelo y miren aquí tenemos la fotografía
de una comunidad aquí hay diferentes
poblaciones de peces y otras cosas como
anémonas y coral
todos comparten esta misma región y
muchos de ellos pueden necesitar en
competencia con otros tal vez vayan tras
la misma comida o quieren ocupar el
mismo lugar y muchas veces cuando se
habla de estas interacciones
interespecíficas verán algo como esto
- diagonal
o si lo quieren ver de otra manera signo
negativo diagonal signo negativo eso
significa que este tipo de interacción
en el que hay dos especies o mejor dicho
dos poblaciones que están en competencia
entre más allá de una tendrá un efecto
negativo en la otra y viceversa por
ejemplo si yo soy una planta y estoy en
competencia con otra planta que se está
llevando mi luz y hay más de esas
plantas evitando que yo pueda tomarlos
eso tiene un efecto negativo en mí y
viceversa o si yo estoy en competencia
contigo y comemos lo mismo entre más
coma yo eso tendrá un impacto negativo
en ti y viceversa ahora la siguiente
forma de interacción inter específica o
de interacción entre especies es la
depredación la depredación es cuando a
una población le gusta comerse a otra
población y tal vez ustedes asocian la
depredación con imágenes como ésta que
pasan en los programas de televisión y
los documentales en donde un leopardo
a una gacela oa un venado o algo por el
estilo de hecho aquí dice que es un
antílope joven bueno esta es una
depredación pero no es la única forma de
depredación porque miren en esta imagen
tenemos a una cabra comiendo pasto y
esto también es depredación no es tan
sangriento ni violento pero sigue siendo
depredación porque tenemos a una especie
que se come a otra especie y en este
caso tenemos a este animal la cabra que
se come el pasto y este tipo específico
de depredación se llama herbivoría pero
es un tipo de depredación entonces
podemos decir depredación diagonal
herbivoría
qué es un caso especial de depredación y
comúnmente verán más diagonal menos
entre más digamos que entre más presas
existan por así decirlo eso beneficia al
depredador pero entre más depredadores
existan eso tendrá un efecto negativo en
la presa ahora existen otro tipo de
interacciones que son interacciones a
largo plazo en los que hay organismos
que muchas veces viven juntos o incluso
que viven uno en el otro y el término
general para estos organismos que
decimos que tienen interacciones
estrechas a largo plazo es simbiosis
simbiosis
pero miren generalmente cuando las
personas hablan de simbiosis se refieren
a dos organismos que se benefician entre
ellos pero en realidad la simbiosis no
se trata solamente de beneficiar al otro
sino que también puede ser que se
lastimen entre ellos de alguna manera o
que tal vez uno se beneficia mientras
que al otro no le importa así que
existen diferentes tipos de simbiosis la
primera de la que podemos hablar es del
parasitismo para
cities mo
el parasitismo se parece mucho a la
depredación en la que entre más se
beneficia el parásito del hospedador o
también llamado hospedero o anfitrión el
hospedero es lastimado por el parásito y
existen muchos ejemplos de parasitismo
aquí tenemos una imagen ampliada de un
piojo y es un ejemplo de parasitismo
para cities mo porque en este caso
podemos decir que el piojo es un
parásito que se beneficia al vivir en el
cabello porque de ahí obtiene su
alimento o puede vivir en el cuero
cabelludo en donde obtiene alimento al
chupar la sangre y también puede dejar
sus huevos en el cabello que para el
piojo es un lugar seguro del resto del
ambiente pero eso es negativo para
nosotros porque nos da comezón pues está
tomando de nuestra sangre y eso es muy
incómodo
entonces el parasitismo es bueno para el
parásito como la depredación es buena
para el depredador y en el caso del
parasitismo no es muy bueno para el
hospedero ahora
existe otra situación en la que hay
beneficios para las dos partes y a eso
se le conoce como mutualismo lo
escribiré de otro color mutualismo
aquí las dos partes se benefician y
generalmente cuando las personas hablan
de simbiosis en realidad se refieren a
mutualismo que es un tipo específico de
simbiosis en la que las dos especies es
decir los dos animales u organismos se
benefician y aquí tenemos un ejemplo de
mutualismo voy a escribir mutualismo
aquí tenemos un pez payaso viviendo con
una anémona de mar la anémona le provee
un hogar al pez payaso mientras que el
pez payaso mantiene lejos a otros peces
que se podrían comer a la anémona así
que los dos organismos se benefician con
esta interacción a la que propiamente se
le conoce como mutualismo y bueno otra
categoría es aquella en la que una
especie se beneficia y la otra es
indiferente entonces si una especie se
beneficia y la otra es un poco
indiferente a eso se le conoce como
comensal ismo
comensal ismo y existen muchos ejemplos
de comercialismo aquí tenemos una imagen
de una bacteria de la piel de hecho
justo ahora tenemos bacterias que viven
en nuestra piel pero no se espanten
porque en realidad muchas veces es algo
bueno muchas veces es mutualismo porque
nos protegen de otras bacterias dañinas
pero generalmente la bacteria se
beneficia vive de los nutrientes de
nuestra piel que es su hábitat pero
muchas veces eso no tiene un impacto en
nosotros ahora el comensal ismo lo
escribiré entre más estudiamos el
comensal ismo más lo entendemos y nos
damos cuenta de que tal vez el hospedero
también se beneficia lo cual es
mutualismo o tal vez el hospedero es
lastimado lo cual es parasitismo así que
muchas veces el comercialismo no es
completamente neutral para el hospedero
porque puede ocurrir alguno de estos
casos todos estos son los diferentes
tipos de interacciones los invito a que
observen
a su alrededor y vea en el mundo que les
rodea no se limiten únicamente a los
animales piensen también en las
bacterias y en las plantas y piensen
cuáles son todas las diferentes
interacciones que ocurren entre las
especies de un hábitat y como las
clasificaría